Romania might be the first country in
the world to legalized corruption.
Yes.
You heard that writes,
in January 2017,
the Romanian parliaments passed an
ordinance which allow politicians to
accept bribes,
have almost $50,000.
These bribes can happen without any
kinds of legal repercussions whatsoever.
Now,
as you can imagine,
this infamous ordinance triggered one of
the biggest political demonstrations
that the country has seen for over 20
years just to the government suspending
them temporarily,
but even after this protests continued
Romanians role,
the used to living in Europe's most
corrupt country,
and this ignominious decree was the
final straw that broke the camel's back.
But the big question is,
how did they get to this point?
So what's going on in a country that
could make its governments passed this
cleans of law without feeling any sort
of shape?
Well,
today we're going to answer this
question.
Before we do that.
Let's take a look at the history.
The European,
North Korea.
Maria,
understand Romanian history without
knowing it out,
Nicolae Ceausescu,
the European,
Kim Jong.
Now other neighboring countries like
Hungary or Bulgaria have suffered
communist dictatorships too.
But the story of Romania is quite
special since Ceausescu came to power in
1974,
his country has been isolated from the
rest and even from the Soviet Union
itself.
Can even food started to become scary.
Yes.
While citizens had the meals rations by
the state Ceausescu,
it spends money building Pharaoh's
palaces.
For instance,
here is the parliaments of Bucharest.
The built in 1983 ends and names of the
biggest administrative building in the
entire world.
This is especially amazing if we take
into account is that the Romanian
population is no bigger than 22 million
inhabitants during the construction of
the building.
More than 20,000 people were employed in
the reynolds.
3,000 died of exhaustion,
but not only that,
Ceausescu forced as citizens to
participate in parades and massive shows
to praise his own image.
Are they chicken activist?
I've met yet.
It's
just like is North Korea and comrades.
Ceausescu was a master in the art of
political repression during the 19
eighties,
an estimate of one in every 30 Romanians
along stevie political police.
It could be a neighbor your or anyone
really leaning any solid.
You said something bad about the leader,
you could end up spending the rest of
your days in jail simply just disappear
nonetheless,
despite all of this being a dictator,
it's not a safe.
Joel
footage is from Ceausescu's last speech
which took place on the 21st of
December,
1989 look good.
His facial expression and how it starts
to tremble.
It was at this moment the audience
started
him.
This is how the biggest protest in
Romanian history started.
Thousands of citizens stepped out on the
streets with national flags or the
Communists symbols had been cut out.
Three days later on Christmas Day of
that year,
Nikolai,
coca school died next to his wife,
killed by his own party colleagues.
His last words were history will,
and so now you might be wondering,
well,
what happens next?
The truth is in such an oppressive
regime is Ceausescu's.
There were no opposition leaders
whatsoever.
Just to make a comparison in Poland's
when the communist regime fell,
there were powerful leaders like Les
Waylay,
some popular support and helps write a
brand new constitution for the country.
Nevertheless,
who do you think succeeded Ceausescu in
Romania?
Well,
what would be his own party comrades
more?
Exactly.
That would be the man who you see on the
screen now and his name is young.
Imagine this government was not willing
to give up the luxuries that they had
during Ceausescu's times,
so I was always happens in cases like
this.
The Romanian regime changed,
but just a little,
of course,
the new constitution allow the other
parties to run for elections and the old
communist party changed its name to the
Social Democratic Party,
but the high ranking officials that
ruled the country during the
dictatorship caps that power during the
19 nineties and two thousands.
So as you probably know,
if power corrupts,
absolute power corrupts absolutely.
That's understanding of this.
In 1995,
50 percent of the Polish economy was
already in private hands.
But in Romania this figure was only 35
percent.
So that's something like,
as an example,
let's take two common terrorists.
Czechoslovakia had a state owned factory
Skoda that was privatized in 1992.
By sharing the ownership among the
workers,
it's Romanian counterpart.
Dacia was not privatized until 1997 and
instead of doing it by sharing it,
it was simply sold to Renner.
In other words,
during the nineties and the two
thousands,
the ruling elite in Romania did whatever
they could in order to keep control of
the economy and the country.
It was only through these actions that
they were able to keep a hold on that.
Wait,
just a second tip,
because corruption was presence at lower
levels as well in the country that had
been so used to scarcity,
it was impossible to get anything
without a little brian.
I want to go to the doctor.
Well,
bring a box of cigarettes with you and
what about to have electricity at home?
A whiskey bottle bends everything sorted
out and that is how in this country
corruption became a way of life
life.
Now you might be wondering,
is it really possible for a country to
work this way?
And the answer is well no.
Remaining and saw how the former
communist republic,
such as the Czech Republic,
Poland,
started enjoying a western standard of
living while they kept surviving on less
than $400 a month.
This is why in the middle of 2000
Romania requested you become a member of
the European Union so that they could
get access to some of those sweet,
sweet EU funds and Brussels basically
said,
okay man,
I'll let you in,
but there's one condition and that
condition was the national
anticorruption directorate in the year
2002,
the Romanian government founded an
agency to chase corruption.
The national anticorruption direct
service for its best few years.
This agency was directed by prosecutors
connected to the party leaders,
so this was basically the Romanian way
of saying,
hey,
look at us.
We're doing great liquid.
All this corruption we're tackling with
cleaning up everything.
But then again,
not surprisingly,
nothing changed.
That was until the year 2013,
that is the year when a woman came to
Leeds,
the director of risk,
a women ready to face everything and
every one and her name is Laura Cod.
Router pervasy
seemed to have been impressed by the
activities of the DNA.
According to one recent poll,
60 percent of people said they trusted
the agency while only 11 percent say
they trusted problem in just two years
because they see his jails more than
1000.
100 politicians accused of corruption
during these years.
Romanians have discovered all of the
dirty things that ruling class were
hiding and these are no small things.
According to an estimate,
corruption accounts for 15 percent of
Romanian GDP.
Virtually all the public sales had some
kind of running involved.
Even the Microsoft licenses that the
civil servants used has a cost of over
$3,
million dollars,
which we use to pay bribes to different
government officials.
Then there was the case of a judge who
was paint around $700,000 in order to
declare someone innocent.
He was actually guilty and this list,
it just goes on and on and on,
and I don't want to make that the rest
of this video,
but since the year 2013,
basically all of these criminals,
they've been filling up the Romanian
jails.
To the point that some of the prisons
have no space anymore,
but not only that Romanian society
itself has started to realize just how
damaging corruption is,
but the real turning points came a
little bit later with this news.
Armenian nightclub fire leaves 27 dead.
This news triggered a wave of protests
all across Romania.
Apparently this could have been avoided
if the club would have met safety
regulations.
That seems the owner,
red bribes the local authorities.
He could open the club without breaking
the rules.
This is how a platform came to be called
the corrupted cheat day or corruption
kills in English through social media.
Romanian started to organize themselves
in protest groups against corruption.
Oh,
but just hold on for a minute because
the best.
It's really yet to come.
The biggest demonstrations in Romanian
history on January the 18th,
2017 at 10:00 PM.
The social democratic government and
it's prime minister does or in grinned.
Deanna passed an emergency.
Bill Pan's.
Yes,
they did do it at night when everyone
was about to go to bed.
So what did this decrease say?
Well,
it said the politicians who accepted
bribes for less than 44,000 euros did
not have to face jail time,
more pay any fines,
nothing at all.
It was absolutely fine with the law to
be bribed up to that.
No.
It should also be noted that they
discussed this little welder beating the
national budget as normal so no one
would notice the change.
So now you might be wondering who can
possibly data passed such a law.
I mean,
what could possibly be the official
reason behind the decriminalization of
embroidery?
Well,
this is the reason given by the Romanian
prime minister
wants to pass the ordinances into law to
ease overcrowding in prisons.
Yes,
this was the actual reason given by the
Romanian government and Bam,
just like that.
Over 3000 corrupt politicians could be
freed and he has.
Well,
it is true that remaining jails were
overcrowded,
is in a country where money is drained
from the system by bribery.
It shouldn't be too difficult to find
new funds for new prisons.
Also,
the fact that the majority of the
generals,
politicians belong to the government
pass.
It does make it slightly more
suspicious.
Date your thing.
Well,
half a million Romanians thought so too,
and they took to the streets of
Bucharest to minutes after the decree
was.
People will feel that they've been
cheated,
that David
obviously established corruption kills
platform.
Its citizens learned about this news
instantly and boy they did not like it
at all,
and that is how the biggest protest in
Romanian streets.
I never dare to think that
this was possible.
I've always thought there was some
logic,
some commonsense that would lead to a
valid law,
but when I saw what happened,
I knew I was wrong.
Protest kept going for days,
not only in Bucharest about in most
Romanian cities,
the first victim of the unrest was the
justice minister who was forced to
resign on the ninth of February 2017.
As we mentioned,
the protests led to the government to
retiring this new law.
Although they have already admitted that
this is just temporary.
Further,
the brand new justice minister to
derailed soda has a clear mission to
justifying the firing of the general
prosecutor.
Laura could recheck a basing women who
are jailed over 1000 politicians.
The government claimed that her agency
is running a witch hunt,
but they still haven't found a way to
legally far her yet
valuating constitutionality,
legality and opportunity factors.
I determined that at the moment it's not
advisable to start the institutional
mechanism to revoke the general
prosecutor and the DNA chief prosecutor.
At the same time Grimsey all news.
Government is confronted going to
different sites.
On the one hand,
civil society is surveying his
movements.
On the other hand,
the European Union is demanding that he
stopped at striking the anticorruption
prosecutor and of course all of the
political elite inheritors of
Ceausescu's regime are turning to
classic conspiracy theories do protect
themselves according to them,
George Soros and the Rothschild family
behind the protesters and they say,
of course,
that corruption is not actually a big
deal in Romania at all.
Well,
with or without conspiracies,
we are still talking about an
existential crisis in Europe,
the poorest
country.
Now the question is,
do you think Romania should jail all of
their corrupted politicians,
or do you think that instead the prime
minister is actually doing something
right by Ge criminalizing bribery?
You can leave your answer in the comment
section below
as case you want to hear another story
about a citizen revolution.
You might want to check out our video
where we tell you about the umbrella
revolution in Hong Kong.
Click on that,
right,
that and also don't forget to visit our
friends at reconsider media dot Com who
provided the voice in this video that
isn't mine,
and please give us a thumbs up if you
enjoyed that video and don't forget we
put our brand new videos every Monday
and Thursday,
so do subscribe to not miss out on any
of them,
and as always,
I'll see you in the next video.
The.